you wake up and you feel like that
inside her mouth is just wearing like a
performance piece of scum
our bodies are wonderful caves of goop
Oh Gweneth Paltrow is she doing
welcome to a Monday morning show of
consciousness flow it is in fact Monday
morning and I kind of like doing these
videos in the morning on Monday morning
with a cup of coffee just talking to you
about all the stuff in my head my head
the interior of it is like a bingo
roulette with all the balls and it
reminds me a tiny version of what the
American Gladiators used to do it and
the run inside those balls land on the
geysers and if they had to inch forward
momentum towards like oh now I get back
on the geyser and then afterwards get
back on that guy
sir cuz you look very masculine nice
what would my American Gladiator name be
hmm this is a great question to everyone
out there what would your American
Gladiator name be uh-oh
my brain is right with ideas not
sergeant very barren ooh
dry harvest I only like storm and so
many meanings
how's your weekend how's your Easter did
that giant freakish animal come into
your house and leave you with chocolates
and hope for Jesus to come again so he
said I'm not insinuating that God is gay
I don't know who Jesus is mamas I mean
it's Mary he's the son of God
and I know that God tonight this state
of dingdong in her dumb ditch supposed
to say maybe God's gay oh what a great
starter the week revelation April taxes
okay I hate that topic that's the only
one fun / terrible thing about taxes is
that you have to go back through all of
your bank statements and figure out what
you have purchased that you can deduct I
don't talk kids it gives you a chance to
look back through your life over the
past year and realize like
your peaks and valleys were emotionally
for me I always know I was going through
a really hard time when there's been a
spike in online clothing purchases along
have you been asking me about its grace
merch so it's greats merch is this
recording oh cool
that would have been such a waste cuz
these have been some real great
inspiring thoughts it's grace merchants
giving figured out there's something
really cool that it's in the works might
be available this come by not saying
definitely cuz it's still get it figured
out if it happens it's really cool this
is a terrible way to talk to you about
it because it's something you bake
something have excitement brewing but
don't let the pot boil over yet don't
start cooking the stew just have the
water simmering definitely makes - Oh
Wendy voting is still open until the
24th and I've been nominated for Best
first person hosting thing if there's a
link down below if you'd like to vote
for me there's no pressure Hank green
Jacob from YouTube nation and Mike
Rugnetta from idea channel are all also
nominated some real dicks I don't know
good try come say hello hi girls hi
goose you wanna come say hello hey goose
hey girls
one come say hello hey goes say hello
usual Mertz she found a peanut on the
floor
dogs are peanuts I'm gonna go google it